The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: What I'd
like to do very quickly
is give you a brief
account-- much
to skeletal and simplified--
of this conversational drama--
the way in which the
Western film becomes
a screen on which American
values are projected,
and on which American
values are tested,
and in which we see American
values or assumptions
undergoing certain kinds
of transformation--
certain kinds of change.
I don't expect you to
remember these titles or all
of these titles although
the ones I talk about you
might think about.
And this is very far from
a complete list of films.
It's just a list of highlights.
But I want to give
you a sense of,
first-- that the Western film
is at the center of movies
at every phase of the
history of the medium.
And as we've noted,
one might argue
that one of the very first
films-- some people have called
it the first narrative
film although that's
a slight exaggeration--
but one of the most
fundamental founding documents
in the history of movies
is, of course, a Western.
If not its first story-- film--
one of the earliest narrative
films was a Western.
And we might note, in fact,
that Western, The Great Train
Robbery, was also
based itself, not
on-- although it has
mythologized and fictionized--
The Great Train Robbery is based
on a historical actuality--
on a robbery that was
very widely covered
in the press about which
dime novels were written
and which became a
site of many films--
the first one The
Great Train Robbery.
A more recent one
that you may have
heard of if you haven't
actually seen it--
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid which tells the same story.
It's based on the same gang.
It doesn't tell
exactly the same story,
but it's based on
the same gang that
was said to have committed
the great train robbery.
And that calls our attention
to another factor--
another aspect-- of
this-- what we might call
the story of the mythological
aspect of American cinema,
and especially of the Western,
because it calls our attention
to the fact that the same
events may be narrated again,
and again, and again.
One of the points about myth--
about collective stories--
is they're literally
told repeatedly.
One way to think about
the Western-- say, OK.
There are variations but,
basically, it's the same story.
Of course, that's a
tremendous simplification
because it's thematic,
and moral implications
can change radically--
but, basically,
the same set of characters,
the same setting,
the same materials told over
and over again, obsessively.
Why would a society do this?
What is driven-- what
drives us to do this?
Well, one answer is there
are pleasures in familiarity.
One of the deepest lessons
of the history of literature
is that the romantic
and modernest idea
of the artist as a unique
individual creating art ab
novo-- sui generis-- with
no connections to the past
is a fantasy and a delusion--
a particular outgrowth
of the romantic
and modern period.
But that throughout history and
throughout most cultures, art,
and especially
storytelling, has been
much more like the activities of
these popular formats in which
the same kinds of stories
are repeated again
and again with variations.
And one could say that one of
the profoundest resemblances
between Shakespeare's
time and our own
is the dominance of genre
forms in a popular theatrical
environment.
In Shakespeare's day, it
was the popular theater
that had a similar effect of
trying to define in some sense
our notion of national identity.
And that's why I quoted
the Renaissance scholar
this afternoon who called
Shakespeare's theater
"the theater of a nation."
He was trying to make
the same kind of argument
about the importance
of the centrality
of the public theater
in Shakespeare's day
that I'm making about the
movies in the United States
in the 20th century.
So The Great Train
Robbery is a kind
of originating text
both for film itself
and for the genre
of the Western.
Griffith's The Battle
of Elderbush Gulch
was one of the
first longer films.
I think it was a half an
hour or 45 minutes long.
It was a much longer
creation than earlier films,
and it was one of the
first major examples
of large crowds of
people-- mounted
people-- engaged in battle.
And that was one of the
most astonishing things.
It was a tremendously
influential film.
It dramatized battles
between cowboys and Indians
in a way that showed the
power of the medium of film
at a very early stage.
In 1914, the first
movie dramatization
of that novel by Owen Wister
that I mentioned earlier-- that
was also one of the founding
texts in the Western genre.
I've mentioned a couple
of other films here.
One of them-- one of John
Ford's earliest films
to demonstrate that--
I've got two Ford films
listed there to try to give
you a sense of his importance
in the silent era.
I list The Covered
Wagon as a way
of showing you that the
genre of the pioneer story
was already present
in the silent era.
I list The Iron Horse by Ford
as a way of reminding you
of how central Ford is but
also a way of reminding you
that that story of the
laying of the railroad--
the Intercontinental Railroad--
one of the central sub
stories-- recurring
stories in the Western
begins in the silent era.
And I mentioned
the Keaton partly
to show you that the genre had
become so widespread that it
was now so fully-fledged--
so fully recognizable--
even in the silent
era that Keaton
was able to make a comic parody
of Westerns called Go West.
With the advent of
sound, the first decade
of the Western movie is,
from an artistic standpoint,
not very distinguished.
Can you guess why one
primary reason is?
If you look, I say singing
cowboys-- because it was sound.
The very first thing
said, oh, well.
We're so enamored of sound.
The novelty of sound
is so remarkable.
The first thing
we'll do is we'll
introduce cowboys who sing.
And there were primitive
stories that they told,
but the stories were
relatively superficial.
I mentioned In Old
Arizona, the first sound
Western, in part because what
was amazing about that film,
especially to audiences,
were literally the sounds--
the crackling of the fire,
the creaking of the saddles.
The noises of the West
were fascinating to people.
So the '30s, from an
artistic standpoint,
were not a very
interesting one in terms
of the Western's development.
Some scholars have argued
that the silent Western
was more interesting than
the Western of the '30s.
But they're worth mentioning
because they were very popular,
and many Westerns in
the '30s were identified
as what were called B-films.
That is to say, as
you may know the-- I
wish I had had
time in this course
to spend some energy talking
about what might be called
the movie house Culture-- how
incredibly the whole society
after about 1930 or
in the early '30s
was permeated by the movies--
how every major city had
dozens-- maybe even more
than that-- of movie houses
showing films that--
many levels of films--
recent films and many
older films as well.
And as I think I mentioned
in an earlier class,
it was possible to go to
third and forth-run movie
houses showing movies that
were several years old
and to pay something like
a quarter in the morning
and go in and watch
five or six movies.
And I did this as a child in
the late '40s in Brooklyn,
New York where I would go into
a theater and come out-- I
would go in in the
bright morning.
I would come out--
it would be dark.
They were lousy movies,
but I was a kid.
I didn't know any
better, and it was
an astonishing kind of culture.
I should also mention, I call
it the movie house culture
because, of course--
again, I haven't had time
to develop this.
But if you google "movie
houses," what will immediately
appear are a series of
magnificent photographs
or images of movie palaces.
You could even google
"movie palaces"
and find the same answer-- that
now mostly fallen into disuse
or destroyed that were
all over the country--
very exotic and remarkable.
Even the physical
structures of these theaters
were exotic and exciting.
These exhibition
spaces were themselves
meant to excite you and
take you into another world.
And partly because of that,
what they always offered
was a really robust
ticket of offerings.
You didn't just go to the
movies and watch one movie.
You saw at least
a double feature.
The second feature
was often what
was called a B-movie-- a second
rate movie-- lower budget.
Many of them were Westerns.
One reason for that was
because the accouterments
of the Western are
so interchangeable.
As I mentioned in
an earlier class,
one of the things they could
do was use stock footage
to put these Westerns
together very quickly.
So they could have
a stampede that
might have appeared in
many different movies
but will do the job in this
B Western and so forth.
And they could use the
same props, the same town,
the same horses, and the
same costumes, and so forth.
So for a lot of the
'30s, the Western movie
was a kind of back-up-- a second
banana to the primary film.
In addition, there began
to develop, especially
on Saturday-- in this
movie house culture,
Saturday mornings were
especially for children--
even Saturday afternoons.
They began to develop what
they called matinees which
were intentionally
devoted toward trying
to get younger people--
children-- into the theaters.
And they had a series of sort
of B or C Westerns some of which
were serials and would continue
from one Saturday to the next.
I want to mention my favorite
childhood Western hero
whom I still remember.
And I remember I loved
this character when
I was seven and eight
years old and would
go to the movies on Saturdays
and see-- sometimes the serials
would last several weeks.
Part of it was to try to get
the kids to come back and get
their parents to pay for them
to come back every Saturday.
So they would always
end with a cliffhanger--
with a moment of great
tension-- and you
wonder whether the
hero and heroin would
survive into the next week.
And there were a whole
series of such films.
My favorite such
film was a film where
a series of adventures
starring a character
named Lash LaRue-- can you
guess what Lash LaRue's weapon
of choice was?
AUDIENCE: A whip.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes,
the whip-- a bullwhip.
He never carried a gun.
But he had this long bullwhip,
and he would take this whip
and he'd go--
[CRACK]
--like that.
And it would snake out across,
and it would flip a gun right
out of a person's hand.
Or he could go--
[CRACK]
--like this, and a
little tiny spot of blood
would appear on a person's nose.
It was a unbelievably,
ridiculous fantasy.
And the lash made a
tremendous beautiful crack
when he brought it back.
He was obviously a figure
of childhood fantasy,
but it was a tremendously,
memorable film.
And, again, there
was no pretensions
toward psychological seriousness
or even thematic density
in these Westerns, but
they permeated the culture.
They were part of the
experience of childhood.
So children in the
society would grow up
watching these children's
versions of Westerns,
and then they would graduate
to the more adult Westerns.
I don't want to call it a form
of brainwashing because that's
much too negative
a way of describing
the way in which these story
forms shape our understandings
or help to shape
our understandings.
And I don't mean that
human beings are completely
programmable creatures-- that
they go and look at a movie,
and they become robots
following what the movie said.
But what I am saying is that
the way these kinds of stories
permeated the society
helped to shape Americans
understanding of their natures--
of what the social fabric was
like, of what masculinity
was, of what femininity was,
of what families were, of what
the relations among the races
were, of what
American history was,
about what the founding
story of America is,
about what the central
organizing values
of our culture are.
All of those things are
dramatized either explicitly
or implicitly in movies.
And because the
movies were so central
through the 20th
century, they were
one of the central ways
in which the belief
system-- the values--
of American society
were promulgated,
dramatized, rehearsed,
and in some ways
altered and changed.
The classical age
of the Western film
is often said to be the
period of the 1940s,
and this is really
the moment when
the Western as an artistic form
begins to come into its own.
Although, it also still carries
ideological or thematic baggage
we might not want to
embrace or celebrate.
So remember, it's an
ambivalent thing here.
I'm asking you to respect
the artistry of these films,
but I'm also asking you to do
something mature and grown-up
which is be skeptical
about the meanings that
are embodied in what are
sometimes very artful movies.
And we call it
the classical age,
in part, because a
certain kind of much more
ambitious
intellectually powerful
and artistically organized
Western begins to appear,
dominated-- but not completely--
by the great director John
Ford-- one of whose
masterpieces you're
going to see in a few minutes.
The age probably begins
in 1939-- the same year
that the integrated
musical begins
with-- what was the film?
We mentioned it last week.
The Wizard of Oz
in which color is
introduced for the first time.
Well, here the genre of the
Western comes into its own,
really, roughly in the
same year in a film that
stars John Wayne, who was
one of the iconic stars
of the American Western,
and directed by John Ford--
his favorite director-- a
director who did other things
but who was noted, especially,
for his remarkable Westerns.
Wayne had had a
career in the movies
10 years before that, but in
Stagecoach, for the first time,
he became a major star.
The film made him a star.
And Stagecoach is
an interesting film
because it articulates
or formulates
one of the great sub
genres within the category
of the Western.
And this is-- I don't know
exactly what to call it.
It's a story in which you
have a group of unlike people
who are traveling,
usually by stagecoach
or in some other-- sometimes it
can be by train-- who are beset
unexpectedly by some
kind of danger-- usually
an attack by Indians.
And then the uneasy
community that
is forced upon
them when they have
to defend themselves reveals
various aspects of human nature
and of human society.
And the film Stagecoach
is a classic instance
of that in which the
John Wayne character gets
on the stagecoach as
it's making a journey
across a bleak Western landscape
through Indian territory.
And he's a, kind
of, ambiguous figure
in this film-- the Wayne
character-- perhaps an outlaw.
And the respectable
people who are
in the stagecoach-- a
banker-- a character who's
actually embezzling money
and is trying to get away
although no one knows.
He hasn't revealed
it at the time.
It comes out in the
course of the film--
and a series of other
sort of characters
with interesting
backgrounds that
emerge when the catastrophe
descends upon them.
And, of course, what happens
is the ambiguity of the Wayne
character-- the fact that
he has a kind of connection
to lawlessness turns out to
be one of the great virtues
that he has because,
of course, he
becomes the primary defender
of the group when they
are beset by savage Indians.
And then I've listed--
again, let me remind you.
Again, I've just picked--
these are just highlights.
Remember what we said.
Nearly 30% of all films
made during the studio era
were Western movies, and these
are among the highlights.
From the titles you can
see the recurring sub
genres that occur.
Billy the Kid in 1941-- the
film directed by David Miller--
this preoccupation with outlaws.
There are a number of
films about Billy the Kid,
a number of films
about Jesse James,
and about the gun fight
at the O.K. Corral.
The 1946 film My Darling
Clementine-- Ford's famous film
starring Henry Fonda-- is one
of six movies made about the gun
fight at the O.K. Corral.
And think of what
that says to us.
What does a myth do?
It tells the same story
again, and again, and again.
Each of those six
films is in many ways
different from-- in
significant ways,
each film is different
from the other film
even though the basic
information, or at least
the basic situation,
is the same.
And, in fact, in some
versions of the film--
in some versions
of that account--
the account of the O.K.
Corral-- Wyatt Earp
and the Earp brothers fight
against the Clanton brothers.
In the classic
versions-- in the version
My Darling Clementine in 1946
by Ford, the Earps are heroes.
And Wyatt Earp is
a great American--
is a noble American hero who
defends a town against anarchy
and evil.
The Clantons are entirely evil.
But in later revisionist
versions of the same story,
Earp and his brothers are
seen as arrogant officials who
are trying to control
gambling and prostitution
in the town of Tombstone.
And the Clantons are
not seen as noble
but are seen,
essentially, as rivals
of the Earps-- not necessarily
as inferior, evil characters.
And such a
perspective, of course,
profoundly changes
our understanding
of what the gun fight
at the O.K. Corral
represented-- interesting
and deeply revealing
that so many Westerns
have been repeated.
I mean, the same story
told again and again.
And so the fact that the
gunfighter at the O.K. Corral
was repeated at least six times
in feature length films-- there
were also television versions
of the O.K. Corral event,
adding to the number--
is a dramatic example
of what we might call
this mythological function
or this forum function--
this discourse space
function that genre forms in
general and the Western movie,
in particular, have.
I've already mentioned Red
River in my earlier discourse
about Howard Hawks.
And I want to just remind
you that that great director
of screwball comedy was also
one of the great directors
of masculine adventure
films including what
many people think is one of the
great Westerns of all time--
Red River.
And Red River is an
interesting sub genre as well.
It's a cattle drive Western.
Many Westerns are
about cattle drive,
but this one also adds a
very interesting complexity
because there's a
kind of oedipal drama
and acted out between the
John Wayne figure-- recurring
figure in so many Westerns--
and a younger man played
by the great actor Montgomery
Clift who plays a surrogate son
to the John Wayne character.
And, of course,
conflict develops
and the rivalry
between father and son
is a fundamental subplot
in that remarkable Western.
One other thing I should say
about the '40s period-- I
call it the classical age
primarily for this reason--
I sort of didn't name this.
Forgive me for not
mentioning this earlier.
Again, we're talking
about the period
just before, during, and
after the Second World War.
The United States feels
itself to be beleaguered.
The world is
beleaguered in a way.
That outer reality
also helps to explain
why the Western of
the 1940s would be,
essentially, a celebration
of American power,
a celebration of
American empire,
American know-how
and competence in the
wilderness because, by analogy,
the Western is a story
of American success--
of American conquest.
One might think of it
as a story that American
needed to tell itself
during the period.
So the war-- the
Second World War
is a great reinforcement
to the way in which--
in the classical age of
the American Western,
the Western film is basically
telling an heroic story,
is celebrating the
conquest of the West,
and is seeing the white
man's settlement of the West
in relatively unambiguously,
admirable terms, celebrating
the courage, and the resilience,
and the physical prowess
of the pioneers and the
great, noble gun fighters
who tamed the West for us.
But by the 1950s, this
confidence has begun to wane.
Part of it is, look--
the war has been over
for a significant time.
American society is
in a peacetime boom
which is going to
build through the '50s.
And it's also a period in
which a certain kind of-- this
was, of course, the
period of my childhood.
I was 10 years old in 1950.
And I remember it vividly.
In fact, saw some
of the films that
are listed here in the
theaters for the first time.
So I mention that to you just to
remind you that, in fact, what
we're talking about is
not ancient history at all
because I actually
experienced some of the films
on this list in my
own actual lifetime
when they were originally
shown in the theaters.
And although I am infinitely
old compared to you guys,
I'm still a vigorous,
functioning human being.
So within my lifetime's
memory, many of these films
were contemporary.
And it's important to
realize how close we
are, in fact, to these times.
But one of things that
begin to appear in the 1950s
was a kind of skepticism
about the social arrangements
in the society.
At first they were
very modest and mild.
There was in the
1950s, for example,
what came to be called a
generation gap in which older
and younger-- in which
there was thought
to be a distance between
older and younger people.
And there was a great concern
in the 1950s for alienated youth
and juvenile delinquency which
was a great catch phrase.
And some of the films of
the 1950s dramatized that.
For example, the film
The Left-Handed Gun
in 1958 starring Paul Newman--
directed by Arthur Penn--
is a story really about--
it's a Billy the Kid story.
Newman plays a Billy
the Kid type character,
but he plays a young boy.
He plays, really,
a post adolescent.
And you can feel that what's
partly being dramatized
there are teenage angst.
There are-- and
what also begins--
in 1952, the film High Noon--
a fragment of which I will show
in next week's lecture when
we talk about McCabe and Mrs.
Miller to do a contrast
with a classical Western
and a post-classical
Western-- that film introduces
certain kinds of contemporary
political concerns.
Many people see High Noon as
a parable about the McCarthy
era-- Senator Joseph
McCarthy and the fear
of-- the paranoia
about communism
and the anti-communist
hysteria of
the late '40s and early 1950s
when the Cold War was just
getting powerfully started.
And High Noon is a kind of
parable about a good man who
turns to-- a sheriff
played by Gary Cooper--
one of the great iconic
heroes of masculinity
of the classical Hollywood
era along with John Wayne.
And Cooper plays a sheriff who
has brought peace to the town.
He's been a sheriff
for many years.
And on his wedding day, he's
marrying a Quaker-- a Quaker
woman.
He's giving up his gun
because a Quaker woman, played
by Grace Kelly-- you'll remember
her from the Hitchcock film
although here she
plays a Western heroin.
She's a Quaker, and he's putting
down his gun to join his wife.
And on his wedding day a
man that he sent to jail
is coming back by the noonday
train to take his revenge.
So the Sheriff spends the early
part of the film going around
to the townspeople--
a town that owes
its life to this great, heroic
sheriff saying, help me.
I'm going to be attacked by
Frank Miller and his gang.
No one will help him.
He's left on his own.
He has to stand by himself
because the town is
too cowardly.
And it's a parable
of the cowardice
of people who deserted--
it's in some sense a,
kind of, left wing argument.
It's a parable
about the cowardice
of people who wouldn't stand
up for folks who were attacked
by Senator McCarthy and
other anti-communists
for being disloyal.
So certain kinds of
political meanings
begin to-- skeptical political
meanings begin to creep in.
And the society that's
dramatized in High Noon
is hardly an admirable society.
The Western culture may
have created a town,
and the town has a church.
And they have a meeting
in the church in the film.
He goes-- it's a Sunday, and
you can hear the church bells.
And he goes to the church,
and he asks for help
from the congregation.
And they won't do it.
They're too cowardly.
And so it's a parable
about cowardice,
and about political dysfunction,
and about communal disloyalty.
Also, already by the 1950s,
before the Hollywood era
has completely concluded
or been obliterated--
Hollywood dominance is still
significant in the 1950s--
the Western has begun to change.
It's begun to reflect
social changes as well
as thematic or
ideological changes that
have to do with the way
the society is altering
after the Second World War.
And a number of the films
that I've listed there
do that kind of thing.
And one can also see in this
listing of so-called adult
Westerns a greater emphasis
on psychological themes--
on the conflict
between individuals.
One very powerful and
interesting instance
of that is a film in 1967
directed by Martin Ritt,
starring the great Paul
Newman, in which Newman
plays a half white,
half Spanish,
or half Indian character.
I think he's an Indian--
a Native American.
And it's a parable about racism.
The Newman character is
angry at both the white
and the Native American society.
He doesn't fit in any place.
But it's especially a
parable about his exclusion,
about the Paul Newman
character's exclusion
from white society, and
about the power of racism.
By the time we get to
the end of the 1960s,
we're beginning
to get films that
have a kind of violence quotient
that's different, and bloodier,
and more disturbing
than the violence we
saw during the classical age.
And we especially associate
this form of violence
with the director Sam
Peckinpah whose film in 1969,
The Wild Bunch, takes
a number of actors
who had been stars
in classic Westerns
and brings them back in a
Western that is much darker
and shows these older
men as-- first of all,
their age is emphasized.
They're sort of
doddering around.
They're my age.
They're in their
late 60s-- early 70s,
and they don't seem as
vigorous as they should be,
for one thing.
I think there are
even scenes in which
their nearsightedness of one of
the characters is dramatized.
But their age and
trembliness is only a part
of their unheroic dimensions.
And we can see that the
film, although it celebrates
these heroes in a certain way--
the celebration is cankered.
It's damaged.
It's a damaged kind
of celebration.
There's a sense that these
men are past their prime,
that they're sleeping
with women who
are far too young with them,
and there's something kind
of disgusting about that.
We see that one of
the actors-- an older
figure-- Robert Ryan--
a very gifted actor who
was in many, many
Westerns and other films
in the classical
age of Hollywood--
plays an agent and very
effective gunfighter.
There's a terrible scene in a
brothel where he's-- she's not
a teenager, but there's a woman
surely 30 years younger than he
who becomes his bedmate.
And there's something sour about
the scene intended, I think,
by the director.
I mean, you can feel it.
It's as if the
Western values have
begun to congeal and sicken
even before we get to the-- what
I'm calling the-- anti-Western.
And, of course, in the
late '60s there also
begins to emerge the
phenomenon I talked about
earlier this afternoon--
how the Italians start
making Westerns--
putting them in Italian
and they find
locations in Europe
that replicate American
deserts and so forth.
And the Italian Westerns,
especially those
that are associated
with Sergio Leone,
have a dark, existential,
almost nihilistic flavor.
And one of the things that Leone
did that was very subversive.
He took characters--
American actors--
who were associated with
great, heroic, idealistic roles
in American Westerns
of the '40s and '50s,
and he put them into
Westerns in which they played
evil villains--
murderers criminals who
had no compassion or pity
for any of their victims.
And there's something shocking
about seeing noble Henry
Fonda who played young Abe
Lincoln in John Ford's movie
and played so many wonderful,
heroic figures including
Wyatt Earp in My Darling
Clementine suddenly turned
into a stone killer.
And that kind of
reversal anticipates
what happens in the 1970s.
And, of course, what happens
in the '70s-- partly,
again, a consequence
of transformations
in American society.
I'll talk a bit about
the cultural history
of the '70s next week when I
talk about film in the '70s
in a systematic way.
But suffice it to
say for now, that
what goes on there is
a series of Westerns
begin to appear
that are permeated
by the anti-establishment values
of the counterculture-- that
are permeated by the
anti-war movement--
because the era of the Vietnam
War-- of tremendous fissures
in American society.
I'll talk more about
this next week,
so I don't want
to repeat myself.
So it's a period in
which American culture
is-- it's conflicted and
divided in a horrific way.
And the Westerns will
begin to reflect that.
And, in fact, the
old heroic enterprise
of the classic Westerns of
the 1940s and early '50s
is suddenly
transformed in a series
of anti-Westerns or
dissenting Westerns.
In 1970, Ralph
Nelson makes a film
called Soldier Blue in which
the American cavalry, the heroes
of so many films including
a trilogy of films
by John Ford made
in the late '40s
called the Cavalry Trilogy
in which-- John Wayne is
in one of those films.
At least one of those
films celebrates
the American-- the blue-suited
cavalry of the Western era.
In Ralph Nelson's film,
the American soldiers
are the enemy.
It's almost-- and
they commit atrocities
that some scholars have
associated with the My Lai
atrocities in Vietnam.
And so the Western
has become a screen
on which America's anxieties
about the Vietnam War
have been projected.
Why would the Western
work so well for this?
One answer is what
I've been saying
all along about
the power of genre
and the power of repetition.
Look, if a thing is
repeated again, and again,
and again, it looks familiar.
When it's so familiar,
what happens?
It licenses
something disturbing.
Because the genre
seems on the surface
to contain so many familiar,
reassuring elements,
those very elements
of reassurance
enable the exploration of
disturbing, or uncertain,
or problematic materials.
And that's one of
the-- and, of course,
because any one of these
films would have nothing
like the power
they actually have
if they existed individually.
But it's because they're part
of this long conversation that
goes back to the
earliest days of movies
that they have the
power that they have.
In 1971, the film starring
Dustin Hoffman, Little Big Man,
is another such
film in which it's
the Indians-- the Native
Americans-- who are the heroes.
And the little, big
man of the title
is played by Dustin Hoffman.
He's a Native American who
has survived Indian massacres
and lives to tell the story.
And, of course,
in 1971-- the film
you'll see next week that
will embody these principles--
Robert Altman's McCabe
and Mrs. Miller.
The Western doesn't disappear.
It doesn't completely
die, but it falls away
as time continues
in part, I think,
because our increasingly
urbanized society
after the 1950s became
less and less amenable.
The Western became less and
less credible or valuable.
It became harder and
harder for most Americans
to identify with
aspects of the Western.
That's one reason.
And other genres begin to take
over, especially the science
fiction genre.
And one of the things
you might think about
if you think about the
rise of science fiction
from the '50s and '60s, and
then especially from the '70s
and beyond, and especially the
rise of the science fiction
film is you can begin to
see a hybridization going on
in which many of the
features of the Western
are superimposed on a
science fiction format.
And, man, I'm sure you can
think of many such examples
of science fiction
films they borrow from
and utilize Western conventions.
So that's one feature-- that
certain kinds of hybridization
in which some of the
features of a Western
begin to appear in other genres.
But, of course, the Western--
because of the resonance
of the form, it
continues to be a space
in which gifted directors
are able to make statements
about the nature of
American society.
And exactly, again, because
of the familiarity of it
and because of the long history
of the themes and discourses
we associate with the
Western, every new Western
is always implicitly
in a conversation
with its ancestors.
And we have in the 1990s a
series of interesting films.
Some of you may have seen them--
Clint Eastwood's Unforgiven,
Kevin Costner's
Dances with Wolves,
two more versions of
the Wyatt Earp story--
Tombstone and Wyatt Earp.
Just a couple of titles from
more recent times-- in 2007,
3:10 to Yuma-- a remake
of an earlier film that I
listed earlier-- a 1957 film.
If you compare
those two films, you
can see how much more violent,
how much more anarchic,
how much less idealizing and
romanticizing the Western
has become.
The Assassination of Jesse James
by the Coward Robert Ford--
a wonderful title
which replicates
exactly the title of
one of those dime novels
appeared in 2007.
And let me mention
two astonishingly
rich and interesting
examples from television.
Television by the '80s
and '90s is already
a rival to the
movies-- has really
replaced the movies in many
ways in terms of complexity
and richness as well as having
replaced the movies somewhat
earlier as our consensus
form-- as our central form.
But two films, especially--
one, the well-known miniseries
Lonesome Dove made from
the Larry McMurtry novel--
one of the best television--
one of the best Westerns
ever made-- a wonderful
multipart story
utilizing the serial
nature of television
to tell a Western with an
expansiveness that the movie
screen can allow but that
the conditions of exhibition
in the movies do not allow.
You can't go back to the movie.
You can't watch a movie for
six hours or eight hours.
And it's much less
convenient to go once a week
for two hours for seven or eight
weeks to see the same story.
Television's a
perfect environment
for that in that sense.
The reduced visual
scale of television
is what keeps the television
from being really as
powerful a medium for the
Western as the movies are.
But still, great
Westerns are made.
And the greatest
of all television
Westerns-- one of the great
Westerns-- one of the greatest
Westerns ever made-- is the
ongoing series-- David Milch's
great series,
Deadwood, that appeared
on HBO from 2004 to
2006 was abruptly
cut-off by the HBO bosses.
In my view, it's the equivalent
in the history of television
to the story of what happened
to the Last Laugh, in which
the producers damaged
a work of art.
But even in its
damaged form, Deadwood
is one of the most remarkable
Westerns ever made.
And it is deeply, deeply,
deeply anarchic, dissenting,
skeptical about human
values and about motives.
It's the opposite of
an idealizing Western.
It sees the West as
emerging-- and Western society
as emerging from human greed,
from entrepreneuring violence
and viciousness, from fear.
From a historical and
intellectual standpoint,
it's a far more
persuasive understanding
of how history evolves, I think,
than earlier idealizing forms--
a deeply disturbing
and powerful text.
So the Western remains even
in its vestigial condition--
even though it's now faded.
It's no longer as
central a format
for an urbanized and
technologized society.
Remember, the United States
before the Second World War
was mostly a rural society.
We only became a suburban
and a fully urban society
after the Second World War.
And the growth of the
suburbs is the great event,
of course, after
the Second World
War-- so that more and
more of the population
found rural spaces alien, and
didn't grow up in big spaces,
and couldn't identify
in the same way
with the Western story.
And the conditions of
experience-- the conditions
of life in the United States--
underwent a transformation
that made the Western much
more of a traditional--
a vestigial voice-- a vestigial
form than a central one.
And we can trace the progress
of that-- of the Western genre's
movement-- from the center
to the more marginal
or peripheral parts of the
society in this history
that I've briefly shown you.
I have a few things to
say about John Ford.
Can you put him up?
I won't spend a lot
of time on this,
but I want to mention
some things about him.
This is a list of some
of his significant films.
Not all that I've listed
here are Westerns,
but you can see a
number of them are.
He begins in the silent era.
He continues robustly
through the sound era--
one of the great directors
of the sound era.
And you can see a film like
Young Mr. Lincoln is not
quite a Western.
Drums Along the Mohawk--
half a Western-- but he
made other films that
were not Westerns.
But the Western was
his signature form.
He was a very unpretentious man.
And when he was introduced
to people he often said,
hello, I'm John Ford.
I direct Westerns.
I make Westerns.
He didn't say, I'm
a film director.
He didn't say, I'm a cineaste.
He didn't say, I'm an
artist in the movies.
He said, I make Westerns.
And I like the unpretentious
of that quality in him.
He was the 13th child of Irish
immigrants-- born in Maine.
His father was a saloon owner.
And at the age of 18, in
1913 after high school,
he followed his brother
Jack to Hollywood
where his brother was a
writer and a director.
He began to work in
his brothers films
as a prop man, and a stunt
man, and a bit actor.
He played a Ku Klux Klansman
in The Birth of a Nation.
So he's a man who's
the first-- why
is Birth of a Nation important?
The first feature-length film
in the United States-- D.W.
Griffith.
And it shows Ford's connection
to the history-- centrality
to the history of
the American film.
And he directed his
first film in 1917
which was a bank
robbery Western.
And in that year he
directed his first feature--
the film I listed earlier
on our little history
of the Western,
Straight Shooting.
And then a series of films
through his career-- 30
silent films by 1921 nearly
all of which have been lost.
So he was a very prolific
director in the silent era.
And, finally, at the
end of his career
he had directed more
than 100 films--
over 60 sound features, 14
Westerns of which at least five
to seven are among the
greatest Westerns ever made.
I won't single out any
particular films here
except to indicate that by the
time we get to the late '50s--
to The Searchers, The Man Who
Shot Liberty Valance, Cheyenne
Autumn, Seven Women-- a
new kind of skepticism
has entered into the idealizing
and heroic tendencies that
were characteristic of Ford's
work in his earlier Westerns.
And one of the reasons
that the film you're
going to see tonight
is so central
is that it may be Ford's most
profoundly ambivalent Western--
the Western in which
his impulse to celebrate
the heroic qualities
of these pioneers
and the resilience and
survival qualities that
were required to survive
in these environments
are very central.
But he's begun to
recognize-- begun
to acknowledge-- what
his earlier films had not
acknowledged-- the moral
complexities of the idea
that the whites should
come and take land
away from the Indians.
He's become to realize that
the settlement of the West
is not an unambiguous, triumphal
story but a more complex
and morally ambiguous tale.
And that moral ambiguity
is at the heart of the film
you're going to see
tonight-- The Searchers.
It has a damaged hero
as you'll recognize.
It's probably John
Wayne's greatest role.
John Wayne-- he
plays a character
named Ethan in the film.
And it's interesting--
maybe Wayne didn't fully
understand how ambivalently
the central character is
treated because he named
his firstborn son Ethan.
It's a strange thing
because the Ethan
that John Wayne plays
here is not really
an attractive person.
He has qualities that we admire
and that John Ford surely
admires.
He's tremendously
good with a gun.
He's deeply knowledgeable about
how to survive in the West.
He knows a tremendous amount
about the Native Americans.
He can ride a horse
like a rodeo rider.
He's brave beyond belief, but
he's also, as we discover,
a racist.
There's a danger all
the way through the film
that he may murder the young
girl he's trying to find.
He's searching for a young girl.
There's some
question all the way
through the film on what his
motive is-- whether he wants
to find her to kill
her or whether he wants
to find her to rescue her.
Why does he want to kill her?
Part of his damage--
the implication
of the early part of the
film is that he-- not just
the implication--
the fact is he--
in the early part
of the film, we
discover that he fought on the
Confederate side of the war,
so he's coming home a loser.
And there's an implication
very early, as you'll see,
that he committed
various kinds of crime--
that he rode with outlaws.
And that some of the loot
that he has taken from the war
may be ill-gained-- that he's a
bitter and unhappy war veteran
who feels that his side lost.
So he enters the film bitter--
as an embittered and damaged
person.
As the film continues,
we recognize
that, in fact, this family he's
returned to-- his brother's
family and his brother's wife
and his nieces and nephews--
there's a complexity there
because of the looks that he
exchanges with his
brother's wife.
You realize, not that they've
ever had an affair or anything,
but they had loved
each other first
and that the wife maybe still
loves the John Wayne character
even though she'll
never act on it.
Watch how that happens
because not a word of dialogue
is spoken, but Ford dramatizes
this almost heavy-handedly.
It's not all ambiguous even
though the character playing
John Wayne's brother is
completely oblivious to this,
but the audience knows this.
So he's an embittered,
damaged-- a partial figure even
from the beginning.
And then as the
story goes on, we
discover other qualities in
him that make us nervous.
I said, for example,
that he may be a racist.
And we don't know whether
he'll kill or save
the person he's after.
The film involves
an Indian attack
in which the John
Wayne character's niece
is taken by Indians.
And most of the film is
the John Wayne character
and his sidekick's
attempt to recover
the stolen woman-- his niece.
She's stolen as a child,
but it takes many years
before they recover her.
And by the time they recover
her, she's a young woman.
And she's been the wife
of an Indian brave--
a character named Scar who
was really, ultimately,
a kind of double of the
hero in certain ways
as we come to recognize when
we look closely at the film.
And his search for this
girl is ambiguous to us
because he's so against--
he hates Indian so much.
It's a form of-- remember when
the film is taking place--
during the civil rights era.
So we can read John
Wayne's hatred of Indians
as a form of the racism--
the anti-African American
prejudice-- that is
being dramatized--
that is being fought
over in the civil rights
movement in the United
States in the '50s and 1960s.
So it's a kind of metaphor
for what's happening there.
And we're not sure whether
the John Wayne character
is actually going to
save her or kill her
when he finds her because she's
been polluted by her connection
to an Indian.
And this theme-- it's not
hidden because the John Wayne
character's sidekick is really
worried about this and even
accuses him of
this at some point.
So he's a damaged and
ambiguous character.
There are things
about him we admire,
but there are things
about him that disturb us.
And at the very end
of the film in what
is one of the most famous
images in John Ford's work,
we get a shot of John
Wayne from the back.
He's been excluded from
the community in a way.
We see him from the back.
He's standing like this.
We see him through an
aperture through a doorway.
And he grabs his-- he makes
this kind of a gesture--
a gesture of vulnerability in
which we-- and he's standing
isolated and alone.
There's a sense in which he's
still-- this extraordinary hero
has been, in some
sense, excluded
from the very community
that he helped
create, in part,
because he doesn't
deserve to be part of it.
He's damaged.
He's imperfect.
But also because of the
natural-- the mythic logic
of the Western in which
the savior figure is so
tainted by the
savagery he saved us
from that he can't be
included in the community
that he helped to create.
So it's a very clear example
of this Western pattern,
but it's morally
complicated because it
comes at such a late stage
and because, by this time,
Ford himself has
begun to reflect
on the implications of the
much more simplistic stories
he had told earlier
in his career.
The setting of the film
is important to talk about
because it is filmed
in a place that
came to be called John
Wayne's own special theater--
his own stage set--
Monument Valley in Arizona.
Other directors have
worked in that place,
but it always feels as if
they're plagiarizing John Ford.
He made at least nine
films in Monument Valley.
And you'll see the
power of that space--
the looming rock
formations-- the sense you
have all the way through the
film that the human habitations
are minimal structures that
could be blown away in a second
and that are dwarfed in
comparison to the rock
formations and the grandeur of
the gigantic natural phenomena
that we see around us.
The human being seems small,
and the human habitations
seem marginal and
far from permanent
in this world of
grandeur-- of what
we might call inhuman grandeur.
So the setting's important.
The plot-- very
important to realize
that it embodies two separate,
important kinds of stories.
The first-- the founding story--
what I've talked about earlier
today.
The idea that this is
how a culture is founded.
You create a society
against warring elements,
rescue it from the
wilderness, and from savage--
not just savage nature but
from savage antagonists--
the American Indians who don't
want to give up their land
and who are-- until we get
to this film-- in John Ford's
films mostly-- had been
figured as anarchic figures
of pure evil.
They hadn't been humanized.
They've been seen
as part of nature.
In this film, not so.
There's a sympathy
for the Indians
that enters this film that
helps to explain its complexity
and its richness.
The second great story is
the captive's tale-- one
of the central and earliest
forms of American narrative.
The captives tale that is told
here is based on a true story.
A woman named Cynthia Ann Parker
was abducted at the age of nine
by Comanches in Texas in 1836.
A novel was written
about that event
by Alan Le May much
after the event.
And Ford's film is
based on the novel.
One of the ironies is
that the real Cynthia
Ann chose her Comanche husband
over her Anglo relatives
when she was rescued.
She didn't want to
leave unlike the novel
and unlike what
happens in the film.
And I mention this,
in part, to remind you
of the romanticizing tendencies
of the American Western.
But still, captives'
tales-- stories
of white people,
especially white women,
captured by Indians
and raised by Indians
were a staple of
the popular cultures
from long before the
history of movies.
And this movie,
like other movies,
dramatizes a version
of that captive's tale.
The structure of the film is
worth calling attention to,
in part, because it's ambiguous.
One way to organize
the plot-- I mean,
the structure of the
film-- is to recognize
that there are seven moments
in the film that we might think
of as chapters or bookmarks.
And if you watch
for these moments--
it's also a structurally
significant device.
If you watch for
these moments, you'll
be able to follow the-- you'll
recognize that the film is
progressing because its
timeframe is intentionally
ambiguous for reasons
I'll hint at in a moment.
And these seven moments all
involve a similar kind of shot.
The camera looks through
a doorway or an opening
out into a rectangle
of receding light.
The very opening of the
film has one such shot.
And at seven different
moments in the film,
we see a shot from inside
an interior space--
from a dark interior space-- and
we look out through a doorway.
You might ask yourself why
in a film that celebrates
and that dramatizes the
immense expansiveness
of the Western environment,
Ford would give us
images-- such self-conscious
obvious images--
that, first of all,
refer to each other
so you think about when
they occur in the film.
But why he would
so intentionally
restrict the visual range
of what's available--
make you feel confinement.
Why does he do that?
One possible-- and I might
leave this for your section
but think about why he does it.
One effect is surely to
make you even more aware
of how expansive the
outside is because you
are in the outside
for a lot of the time.
By confining your
vision in this way,
it's a reminder of how
much bigness is out there.
But there are other
reasons, as well,
for why the perspective
would be restricted
to these aperture shots.
In any case, there are seven
of them through the film,
and they mark the
progress of the film.
The reason that the film
is so hard to follow
is, in part, that the
timeframe is weird.
And I'll come to
that in a second.
There is one turning
point in the film
that I want to mention to you
that you should watch for.
It's a moral turning point or
a psychologically important
turning point because it's
a moment in the film where
the sympathy of the
viewer is shifted--
is radically transformed.
It occurs about midway
through the film
where the John Wayne character
and his sidekick, Martin
Pawley, come riding down
a-- not quite a mountain
but a promontory
through heavy snow.
The weather in the film is
interesting and powerful.
That's one of the ways
you can feel time passing.
Their winters and summers go by.
You can feel the
seasons passing.
But you're not clear
how much time goes by.
By the end of the film,
you know many years
has gone by-- at
least 10 years--
because the young girl who was
stolen away in the beginning
is a young woman at the end
of the film-- the adult played
by the actress Natalie Wood--
a very successful and important
actress of the '50s and '60s.
So she's a grown
woman by the end,
so we know that a significant
amount of time has gone by.
But it isn't clear
as the story's
going on exactly how
much time has gone by,
and that ambiguity's important.
The turning point occurs as
they're coming down this hill.
The horses are almost up
to their shoulders in snow.
And they come riding down
this hill into a village--
an Indian village-- a
Native American village.
And it's a Native
American village
that's in smoking ruins.
It has been decimated
by American cavalry.
And they go into
one of the teepees,
and they find--
dead in the teepee--
a Native American woman--
a squaw named Look
who had been following them.
And we've gotten to know her.
And the Martin
Pawley character--
the secondary character--
the sidekick--
says to the John
Wayne character,
why did they have to kill Look?
She didn't do anything.
And it's a moment in which the
butchery of the white soldiers
is dramatized in which your
sympathy turns entirely
away from the official
American government
account of the West
towards something else.
And in the very next scene,
something amazing happens.
It's easy to miss because
it happens so quickly,
but it's very important,
morally, to the film.
We have a scene in which we
see three Indian chieftains
standing in-- they're captives--
standing in blankets looking on
as another group of Native
Americans-- Indians--
are being, essentially,
herded into a compound--
into a hospital-type building.
And they're being herded as
if they're cattle, or sheep,
or not fully human.
And you can see--
there's no dialogue,
but you can see the
sadness and the unhappiness
and the regret in the eyes
of these sturdy chiefs
as they look upon that.
And what happens
in that moment is
that the film's
perspective has become
that of the Native Americans.
And the audience's perspective
has become that as well.
And so the effect
of these moments
coupled with many other things
in the film-- some of which
I've mentioned,
some of which I've
not-- about the ambiguity of the
John Wayne character's nature,
come together here.
And this is a moment
in which something
of the complexity
of the Western story
is being acknowledged
by the text.
No longer are we getting a
kind of simple celebration
of these Western values.
Something much more
ambiguous and morally complex
is happening here.
A critique of those
values is being
embedded in this
apparently classic Western.
And it's one of the reasons
it's such a remarkable film.
I'll conclude now.
I apologize for running over.
The title itself clarifies some
of the ambiguity of the movie.
What are they searching for?
I said before that the timeframe
of the film is confusing,
and it's not just that.
Even the setting of the film--
the Monument Valley setting--
comes to seem almost
like a lunar landscape
before we're finished
with the film.
There's a sense that the
quest goes on forever--
that they begin to lose a
sense of why they're doing it.
After all, so much
time has gone by.
She's lived with the Native
Americans all this time.
What's the point of the
rescue even-- we might think.
The fact that the quest has
gone on for such a long time,
but it becomes more
and more unclear
why the search is going on--
what the purpose of the search
is.
There's a kind of
ambiguity in it
that is deeply disturbing
and deeply troubling.
And, of course, the sense we
have at the end of the film
that the search-- it is
concluded, but almost
until the very
end we're not sure
whether the John Wayne character
is going to save or murder
the object of his quest.
And there's also the sense
that even after he's done,
what has been gained?
So there's a deep ambiguity
at the end of the movie
as there is a deep ambiguity
surrounding the alleged heroism
of the John Wayne character.
So one of the reasons I
emphasize these ambiguities
and complexities is as a
way of stressing the fact
that even before we get
to the era of what I'll
call the anti-Western or
the dissenting Western,
the classic Western itself has
reached a level of complexity
and maturity,
embodied especially
in this film and others
that we might cite
from the 1960s, in which a
kind of self-consciousness
about the assumptions that
lie behind and animate
this central American form have
already come to the surface
and are being confronted
by our best directors
in our best films.
Goodnight.